This is how Jesus Christ was born.
A young woman named Mary was engaged to Joseph from King David's family.
But before they were married,...
...she learned she was going to have a baby by God's Holy Spirit.
Joseph was a good man and did not want to embarrass Mary in front of everyone,...
...so he decided to quietly call off the wedding.
While Joseph was thinking about this, an angel from the Lord came to him in a dream.
The angel said, "Joseph, the baby that Mary will have is from the Holy Spirit."
"Go ahead and marry her. "
"Then after the baby is born, name him Jesus,..."
"...because he will save his people from their sins."
So the Lord's promise came true, just as the prophet had said,...
"A virgin will have a baby boy, and he will be called Emmanuel,..."
...which means "God is with us."
After Joseph woke up, he and Mary were soon married,...
...just as the Lord's angel had told him to do.